Hier ist es so idyllisch.
Das ist der Wahnsinn, nicht?
Die Morgenstille,
die Grillen, einige Kuhglocken ...
Der Traum vom Landleben -
so stellen wir ihn uns vor.
Aber ist das die Realität?
Das möchte ich herausfinden.
Macht Landleben glücklich?
* Sanfte Musik *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Morgen!
- Guten Morgen!
Haben sie schon Frühstück bekommen?
- Genau.
Ich bin in Dittingen,
Kanton Baselland.
Das gehört nicht dazu.
Ah, dort ist jemand.
Hier ist es.
Ich habe mich
mit jungen Frauen verabredet,
die hier
eine Land-WG gegründet haben.
Geht man auf dem Land einfach rein?
Ich komme. Achtung!
Hallo?
Darf ich einfach reinkommen?
- (Mira) Ja, sicher.
Ich bin Mona.
- Freut mich. Ich bin Mira.
Schön, seid ihr hier.
- Du hast mir geschrieben.
Genau.
Ich bin gespannt
auf eure Frauen-WG auf dem Land.
Für diese Sendung habe ich
auf Social Media Menschen gesucht,
die mir
vom Landleben erzählen können.
U.a. hat mich diese WG kontaktiert.
Nein, das haben sie
beim Renovieren gemacht.
Zwei, nein, drei Mitbewohner.
Jetzt sind gerade alle hier.
Das ist Catherine.
- Ich bin Mona. Freut mich!
Die mit den blonden Haaren
ist Johanna.
Und dort hinten ist Manuela. Genau.
Das sind meine drei Mitbewohnerinnen
von hier oben.
Und dann noch Angela,
die auch dazugehört.
Wie viele seid ihr? Nicht vier?
- Fünf.
Ah, ich dachte, ihr wärt zu viert.
- Nein, mit Angela sind es fünf.
Und was ist das
für eine fancy kleine Brücke?
Das ist ein Steg.
Der war schon hier bevor wir kamen.
Und was ist dort hinten?
Ein kleines Häuschen,
in dem wir essen, reden oder so.
Das ist ein Traum, was ihr hier habt.
Das wisst ihr, nicht?
Ja.
Mira ist die Gründerin
dieser WG auf dem Land.
Die Zusammensetzung
hat schon einige Male geändert.
Die meisten, die hier wohnen,
haben sich vorher nicht gekannt.
Dass es nur Frauen sind, sei Zufall.
Das habe sich einfach so ergeben.
Der gemeinsame Nenner
der Wohngemeinschaft:
Sie wollen nachhaltig
und umweltbewusst leben.
Was macht ihr da?
Das ist anscheinend Löwenzahnkaffee.
Kaffeeersatz.
Aus Löwenzahnwurzeln, nicht?
Unsere Nachbarin Dominique hat den
aus getrockneten Wurzeln gemacht.
Löwenzahnkaffee.
Wollt ihr ihn mit Hafermilch?
- Probieren wir einen Schluck,
dann sehen wir,
ob wir noch etwas brauchen.
Es schmeckt schon nicht nach Kaffee.
- Nein, nein.
Sag du zuerst etwas!
Überhaupt nicht wie Kaffee.
Nicht so gut wie Chicorée-Kaffee
und überhaupt nicht so gut
wie normaler Kaffee.
Es ist gesund für die Leber.
Ja, dann.
Noch ein bisschen Zucker.
Zucker würde helfen. Gut.
- Noch mehr?
Die Frauen sind alle um die 25,
arbeiten als Fachfrau Betreuung,
sind Organisationsentwicklerin
oder studieren noch.
Und alle haben vorher
entweder in der Stadt
oder mitten in der Agglo gewohnt.
Du hast mir vorhin gesagt,
aus der Stadt wegzugehen, war nötig.
Was heisst das?
Ich merkte, dass es mich
nicht glücklich machte,
obwohl ich alles hatte,
von dem ich das Gefühl hatte,
ich hätte es schon lange gewollt.
Welche Vorstellung
hattest du vom Stadtleben?
Ein schönes, minimalistisches
Zimmer, alles passt zusammen,
eine schöne Wohnung
mitten im Trubel.
Und dann merkte ich ...
Ich hatte Borreliose und
erholte mich nicht richtig davon.
Ich merkte, dass ich mich
in der Stadt nicht erholen kann.
Ich hatte dort
nicht genügend Ressourcen,
um mich wieder zu stärken.
Es zog sich so lange hin
und dies war das Resultat.
Es war
schon nicht mehr so dramatisch,
aber ich merkte,
dass ich einen Ort wollte,
der mich nährt, nicht auslaugt.
Die meisten in euerm Alter
gehen in die Stadt,
weil dort die Party ist und man
das Leben richtig geniessen kann.
Ihr habt das Gegenteil gemacht.
Was haben eure Kollegen dazu gesagt?
Dann sehen wir uns nie wieder.
Ja. Auch meine beste Freundin
war noch nicht so oft hier.
Es ist auch praktischer, sie zu
besuchen, wenn ich in der Stadt bin,
damit sie nicht eine Stunde
her- und zurückfahren muss.
Es war schon so:
"Du wohnst ganz schön weit weg. Uh."
Es bestand schon die Angst,
dass man sich
wegen des Wegs nicht mehr sieht.
Ich gehe in die Stadt,
um Leute zu besuchen.
Die meisten Leute
kommen nicht hierher.
Was hast du auf dem Land gesucht?
Welche Idealvorstellung hattest du?
Das hier war meine Idealvorstellung.
Die Beziehung zur Natur
ist allen hier wichtig.
In ihrem Permakulturgarten
probieren sie Anbaumethoden aus,
die nicht nur für den Menschen,
sondern auch für die Natur stimmen.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Obwohl es hier aussieht,
als wäre man komplett auf dem Land,
gehört Dittingen offiziell zum
äussersten Zipfel der Basler Agglo.
Stadt und Land
geografisch klar zu unterscheiden
ist in der Schweiz
nicht mehr zeitgemäss.
Dittingen ist eine Mischung
aus urban und ländlich,
wie so viele Gemeinden
in der Schweiz.
Laut Statistik schwanken
solche Gebiete häufig auch politisch
zwischen ländlich-bewahrend
und städtisch-weltoffen.
Bei dieser WG geht es denn auch
um mehr als das eigene Glück.
Ich mache das nicht für mich,
sondern für alle,
die nach mir kommen.
Ich möchte mithelfen.
Ich weiss,
dass ich das nicht alleine kann.
Es braucht ganz viele, aber ich -
oder wir - sind auch ein Teil davon.
Wir wollen Schritte gehen,
die uns in eine Welt bringen,
in der eine Zukunft
überhaupt möglich ist.
Ich fühle eine grosse Verantwortung,
da mitzuhelfen.
Du willst die Welt verbessern.
- Ja. Ja.
Das kann man auch mal so sagen.
- Ja.
Und ich glaube,
das wollen sehr viele Menschen.
Es ist sehr wichtig, herauszufinden,
wie man eine echte Verbesserung
erreichen kann,
die kein Rückschritt ist.
Seid ihr denn Idealistinnen?
Sind Idealistinnen nicht Leute,
die von so etwas träumen,
aber nichts Konkretes tun?
Nicht wahr?
Wir tun ja etwas.
Das habe ich dir
auch gestern erzählt.
In letzter Zeit habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich das erleben darf,
was vor einigen Jahren
mein Ideal war.
Und jetzt ist es konkret geworden.
Mein Traum ist wahr geworden.
Man merkt,
Mira und ihre Kolleginnen
haben sich auf dem Land
schon sehr gut eingelebt.
Aber auf unseren Aufruf
in den sozialen Medien
haben sich auch Leute gemeldet,
die diesen Schritt erst jetzt machen.
Wir haben sie dabei begleitet.
Wir sollten nicht zu viele Bücher
in eine Kiste packen,
sonst wird sie zu schwer.
- Ich habe sonst noch ...
Wir könnten noch
Motorradbekleidung reinpacken.
T-Shirts oder so.
Geht das noch?
- Gerade noch.
Für unsere Umzugshelfer habe ich
jedem Raum eine Nummer gegeben,
damit man weiss,
wohin die Kisten kommen.
Xenia Sägesser und Tinu Strebel
wollen raus aus der Stadt.
Sie bauen sich ein Haus auf dem Land.
Es gibt genügend Platz für alles.
Ich denke, wenn man in der Stadt
gerne etwas mehr Platz hätte ...
Unsere Hobbys brauchen etwas Platz,
einen grossen Bastelraum, eine
Garage und einen grossen Garten.
Und sie machen Lärm.
- Ja, genau. Sie machen Lärm.
Wenn ich zu Hause etwas schreinern
oder basteln will,
wird es schnell mal laut.
Und wenn man
in einem Altbau wohnt ...
Man hat auch nicht genügend Platz.
... basteln elf Haushalte mit,
ob sie wollen oder nicht.
Ja, so ist das in einem Altbau.
Und wenn man
in der Stadt etwas sucht,
wo man mehr Platz hat,
ist es nicht bezahlbar.
Die Wohnungen im Haus nebenan
wurden für über 1 Mio. Fr. verkauft.
Und die sind gleich gross
wie die Wohnung hier, 66 m2.
Die beiden wohnen in der Stadt Bern
und gehören damit
zu einer grossen Mehrheit.
Denn Dreiviertel
der Schweizer Bevölkerung
lebt in städtischem Gebiet.
Während der Pandemie
haben Städte erstmals seit Langem
an Attraktivität verloren.
Wer es sich leisten konnte,
flüchtete aufs Land.
Ich packe unsere Reisebücher
auch ein.
Die haben zwar nichts
mit der Küche zu tun.
Bei Tinu Strebel
und Xenia Sägesser
gab nicht die Pandemie Ausschlag
für den Wegzug aus der Stadt,
sondern eine dreijährige
Motorradreise um die Welt.
Wir hatten drei Jahre lang
eine unglaubliche Freiheit.
Unterwegs zu sein, ist die grösste
Freiheit, die man haben kann.
Wir campierten auch oft
mitten in der Natur
und sahen keine Menschenseele.
Dort hat sich herauskristallisiert,
dass wir das sehr schätzen.
Und ich denke,
das ist auch ein Grund,
weshalb wir aufs Land ziehen:
weil wir
mehr Freiheit um uns herum brauchen,
mehr Freiheit in der Umgebung,
weniger Häuser in der Nähe,
weniger Leute um uns rum.
Wir haben beide gemerkt,
dass wir das sehr gerne haben.
So, dann nehmen wir doch
das Waschbecken noch mit.
Ist gut.
- Wenn wir schon rausfahren.
Es geht ins Emmental.
Dort bauen die beiden
ihr zukünftiges Daheim.
Let me see! Woah!
Look, a ladybug!
Erica und Rolf Knecht zogen vor
einem Jahr, zu Beginn der Pandemie,
von der Millionenmetropole
Kuala Lumpur
nach Meiringen im Berner Oberland.
Straight away. Listen to Mommy
and she will show you what to do.
Für mich fühlt es sich
einfach richtig an.
Weniger Stress, weniger Druck.
Man hat mehr Zeit zum Leben,
mehr Zeit,
um als Familie zusammen zu sein.
Ich finde, wir entdecken
uns selber wieder ganz neu
und merken, wie wir
in diese Landschaft passen.
Das Ländliche,
das Spielerische mit den Kindern,
draussen sein -
das müssen wir alles neu lernen
und wieder entdecken.
Sie haben Mühe
mit dem ganz anderen Untergrund.
Am Anfang wollte keiner
der drei auf dem Gras laufen.
Nach einer Aufwärmphase
ging es dann.
Sand am Strand ist kein Problem,
aber Gras oder Kieselsteine
finden sie ganz blöd,
z.B. Steinböden im Fluss.
Meine Güte, war das ein Kampf,
bis sie lange Hosen
oder Wanderschuhe anzogen!
Sie wollten nur Shorts
und Birkenstock.
Manche Leute haben Vorurteile
gegenüber dem Kleinstadtleben.
Sie denken,
es wäre für sie unmöglich.
Ich dachte das auch.
Ich lebte in Städten
mit 25 Mio. Menschen
und fühlte mich
glücklich und zufrieden
und dachte: "Da gehöre ich hin."
Doch das Leben brachte uns hierher
und ich merke: Es geht.
Ich versuche,
das Schöne zu sehen und zu schätzen.
Es gibt Schönheit, wo immer du bist.
My name is Rolf. I'm the Executive
Chef of Grand Hyatt Kuala Lumpur.
20 Jahre
arbeitete der gebürtige Schweizer
und gelernte Koch Rolf Knecht
in Luxushotels im Ausland.
For me,
working for Hyatt is very special.
It's almost a dream come true.
Einst hatte er
für Grand Hyatt Shanghai
38 Restaurants
und 780 Leute unter sich.
Arbeit war für ihn das Leben,
14-Stunden-Tage die Regel.
Zuletzt sei er wohl
einem Burn-out nahe gewesen.
Some of the best things
Malaysia has to offer.
I hope to see you soon
at Grand Hyatt KL.
Looking forward to cook for you.
* Kuhglocken *
Luxushotels sind für Knecht passé.
Jetzt kocht er für die 120
Privatschüler und 40 Lehrpersonen
der École d'Humanité in Hasliberg.
Ein Bankett für 4'500 Leute
mit diesem Prinz,
diesem Scheich, diesem König
oder wem auch immer -
das stimmt nicht mehr.
Ich möchte, dass meine Kinder
ein Zuhause haben,
dass sie sagen können,
wir seien von hier.
Kein Hummer mehr,
kein Rindsfilet mehr,
aber ich darf wieder richtig kochen,
mit natürlichen Produkten,
von denen ich weiss,
woher sie kommen.
Aber wenn uns vor zwei Jahren
jemand gesagt hätte,
wir würden aufs Land ziehen,
hätten wir gesagt, er sei verrückt.
Zu Knechts Aufgaben an der Schule
gehört auch der Aussenbereich.
Das ist ein Projekt,
an dem wir dran sind:
einen Weg in den Garten zu bauen.
Hier haben wir
ein asiatisches Terrassensystem.
Dort oben haben wir Bienen,
mit denen wir etwas experimentieren.
Die Idee ist,
einen Permakulturgarten aufzubauen.
Ich bin zum einen Küchenchef
und zum anderen verantwortlich
für die Hauswirtschaft ...
... Maintenance, Sicherheit ...
Weil ich in Asien in Hochhäusern
und Wolkenkratzern gearbeitet habe,
habe ich die ganzen Ausbildungen
für Feuerlöschen, Bombenalarm
und - wie sagt man? -
Shooting attacks.
Das mussten wir alles machen.
Ich bin zertifiziert
bis zum Gehtnichtmehr.
Jetzt bin ich hier auch noch
für die Sicherheit verantwortlich
und Hauswirtschaft und Maintenance
und Garten. Und Garten.
Langweilig wird es bestimmt nicht.
Die Umstellung auf dieses komplett
andere Leben mitten in der Natur
sei allerdings
nicht ganz einfach gewesen.
Die ersten sechs Monate
waren ein Kulturschock.
Wo sind meine Wolkenkratzer?
Wo ist mein Hochhaus?
Wir kamen nach dem Flug
abends um 22 Uhr in Meiringen an.
Mein Sohn sagte: "What's happening
with my face? It's burning!"
Es war so kalt.
Er kannte die Kälte nicht.
Er hatte noch nie
richtig Schnee gesehen.
Ja, aber jetzt ...
Glück. Und wirklich das Gefühl,
dass wir das Richtige gemacht haben.
Wir haben wirklich
das Richtige gemacht.
Ein ländlich geprägtes Dorf
mit viel Grün.
Das ist laut einer Umfrage des Bundes
aus dem Jahr 2018
die beliebteste Wohnumgebung
hierzulande.
Wir sind in Schafhausen im Emmental.
Xenia Sägesser und Tinu Strebel,
das Paar, das nach über zehn Jahren
die Stadt Bern verlässt,
baut sich hier ein Haus.
Es sind ziemlich viele Quadratmeter,
die wir hier selber machen.
Man baut wirklich eine emotionale
Bindung mit diesem Objekt auf.
Das ist schon speziell.
Ja. Es ist der Hammer.
Meistens.
Es ist sehr anstrengend,
aber es ist der Hammer.
Ein eigenes Haus mit Umschwung.
Über die Hälfte der Bevölkerung
in der Schweiz träumt davon.
Uns gehört im Prinzip
alles von dort bis dort,
wo der schöne Rasen anfängt.
Dort unten wollen wir
ein kleines Plätzchen zum Sitzen.
Nichts Grossartiges,
weil man am Bach nichts bauen darf.
Aber etwas,
damit man den Bach geniessen kann.
Damit man Cervelats braten kann.
- Genau.
Das Plätzchen, das wir in der Stadt
gemietet hatten, war auch schön.
Aber wenn man hierherkommt
und man hört den Bach plätschern ...
Das ist unverbaubares Land.
Dahinter ist gleich der Wald.
Wir sind in 5 Min. im Wald oben.
Ja, Strasse und Bahn.
Es ist schon so: Wenn man
in der Schweiz aufs Land zieht,
ist man meistens
trotzdem an einer Strasse.
Ein bisschen Mobilität
muss ja trotzdem sein.
Es ist ein Kompromiss.
Hier haben wir mehr Platz,
haben ein Bächlein.
Ich glaube, es ist
ein sehr schöner Kompromiss.
Glaube ich auch.
- Von beidem ein bisschen.
Was kommt hier rein?
- Das Gästezimmer.
Aber falls wir mal Kinder haben,
wäre das das Kinderzimmer.
Die Nachbarskinder
erhalten eine Hausführung.
Hier kommt der Ofen hin,
der auch unsere Bodenheizung ...
Durchschnittlich 46 m2 Wohnfläche
beansprucht eine Person
in der Schweiz.
Hier kommt die grosse Küche hin,
die Martin
nächste Woche installiert.
Dieser Bereich hier.
Wer mehr Platz möchte,
geht in die Agglo
oder eben aufs Land,
wie Tinu und Xenia.
Wir haben riesiges Glück.
Wir haben hier etwas,
das man sich nicht aussuchen kann:
Nachbarn.
Wir kennen bereits alle Nachbarn.
Wir waren schon
zu Grillpartys eingeladen,
wir waren schon
zum Essen eingeladen,
zu Apéros,
zum Frühstück, zum Glühwein.
Wir kennen alle Nachbarn
in den umliegenden Häusern.
Das sind alles supernette Leute.
Man muss Glück haben.
Das ist etwas,
das man sich nicht aussuchen kann.
Schon gar nicht,
wenn man ein Haus kauft oder baut.
Dann geht es nur ums Land und man
hat keine Ahnung, was rundum ist.
Geniesst ihr das Wasser?
(Frau) Ja.
- Am Baden.
Es ist etwas kalt.
- Ist es kalt? Ah so.
Es wird schon noch wärmer.
Wir freuen uns sehr,
dass sie endlich hierherziehen
und wir hin und wieder zusammen
einen Kaffee trinken können.
Ja.
Es ist eine Art Community,
aber alle haben ihr eigenes Haus.
Aber man ist schon
nahe beieinander -
im Guten und im Schlechten,
je nach Betrachtungsweise.
Es gibt sicher Leute,
die nicht gerne aufs Land ziehen -
wegen der sozialen Kontrolle.
Man weiss von allen,
was gerade los ist.
Das stimmt schon.
Aber man ist sich dessen
auch bewusst,
dass man, wenn man aufs Land zieht,
unter Kontrolle ist.
Hugie!
Eat your food!
Eat your veggies too, okay?
Not just pasta and cheese.
Zurück bei Familie Knecht, die von
der Millionenmetropole Kuala Lumpur
nach Meiringen gezogen ist.
Guten Appetit.
Die älteste Tochter, Stella,
kam in Japan zur Welt,
die jüngste, Lyra, in China,
Sohn Hugo in Indonesien.
Die Kinder waren an vieles gewöhnt,
nur nicht an eine Ortschaft
in den Schweizer Bergen.
Zuerst war es
sehr hart für die Kinder.
Sie waren völlig durcheinander.
Alles war anders für sie.
Sie mussten in eine Schule gehen,
in der sie
die Sprache nicht verstanden.
Und sie mussten Regeln einhalten,
die ihnen fremd waren.
Aber sie schafften es.
Mein Sohn spricht jetzt Berndeutsch,
meine Tochter Hochdeutsch.
Sie haben Freunde
und wurden so unabhängig,
wie man es
wohl nur in der Schweiz werden kann.
Ich finde das grossartig.
Es macht die Kinder stolz,
wenn sie im Laden
alleine Milch kaufen gehen können.
They can go off
and do something on their own.
Das ist wirklich toll.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass die Schule
viel mehr Erwartungen an die Kinder
in Sachen Selbstständigkeit hat.
In Asien werden sie verhätschelt.
Da ziehen sie den Kindern
die Jacke an.
Da hat man in einem Kindergarten
mit 18 Schülern
fünf Lehrer und zwei Helferinnen.
Hier ist es eine oder zwei
Lehrerinnen für 20 Kindergärtner.
Man zieht die Jacke selber an.
Es wird erwartet,
dass Kinder Velo fahren können
oder Rollschuh fahren.
Das konnten unsere alles nicht.
Das alles
hätten ihre Kinder nun hier,
in dieser ländlichen Umgebung,
gelernt,
sagen die Kosmopoliten
Rolf und Erica Knecht.
Ich mag Städte,
die vibrieren und chaotisch sind.
Es gibt dort
so viele interessante Dinge:
grossartiges Essen,
tolle Yogastudios, Museen, Kunst.
Hier gibt es nichts von all dem.
Etwas finde ich hier aber speziell:
Du bist inmitten der Berge.
Wenn du draussen bist,
geht dein Blick immer nach oben.
Du schaust zu den Bergspitzen
und denkst:
"Dort oben
gibt es Wildnis und Ruhe."
Du wirst demütig
und kommst dir
mit deinen Problemen ganz klein vor.
Wir werden erst noch rausfinden,
ob es die richtige Entscheidung war.
Bis jetzt stimmt es.
Du bist viel weniger gestresst.
Ich bin viel weniger gestresst,
ich bin mehr zu Hause,
ich bin präsenter.
Was mal gut und mal schlecht ist,
weil es zu neuen Konflikten kommt,
wenn ich ständig zu Hause bin.
Hey, Kinder, nicht spucken, okay?
Guys, if you're gonna do that ...
Geht dort rüber
mit den Kirschsteinen!
Ich glaube, solange die Kinder noch
wachsen und sich weiterentwickeln,
bleiben wir sicher hier,
damit wir ein Zuhause haben.
Wenn wir mal 70 oder 80 sind ...
Wer weiss, ob wir in
einem Altersheim in der Stadt sind
oder ob wir bis zum Schluss
in Meiringen bleiben?
Ich brauche das Herumreisen
nicht mehr.
Ausser meine Frau sagt:
"Hey, die Kinder sind draussen,
gehen wir nach Kanada!"
"Geniessen wir dort die Pension!"
Wieso nicht?
Nein, wir gehen nicht nach Kanada.
- Maybe Bali.
Yeah.
Hin- und hergerissen zu sein,
wo wir leben wollen
und was uns wirklich guttut -
ich glaube,
das kennen wir alle irgendwie.
Woher kommt das eigentlich?
Um eine Antwort auf diese Frage
zu finden, treffe ich in Basel
die Philosophin und Moderatorin der
"SRF Sternstunde", Barbara Bleisch.
Immer wieder haben Philosoph:innen
sich gefragt,
warum es Menschen aufs Land zieht.
Warum ist das ein Sehnsuchtsort?
Und viele haben das Land verteidigt.
Aber dabei ging es
nicht nur um Land und Natur,
sondern oft auch um die Flucht
vor der Gesellschaft.
Was macht das Land
zu einem Sehnsuchtsort?
Beim Philosophen
Jean-Jacques Rousseau
ist die Idee
"Weg von der Zivilisation".
Man verbindet ihn mit dem Satz
"Zurück zur Natur",
was er so verkürzt
aber nie gesagt hat.
Rousseau sagte,
der Mensch sei frei geboren,
aber überall läge er in Ketten.
Damit meinte er
v.a. die Gesellschaft,
die den Menschen
nicht frei sein lässt, wie er ist.
Überall werden wir vereinnahmt
und fremdbestimmt.
Für ihn war die Flucht aufs Land
v.a. eine Flucht
vor dieser Gesellschaft.
Heute ...
- Und Freiheit.
Und Freiheit. Und heute,
glaube ich, gibt es wirklich beides.
Die einen wollen wirklich weg
von der Zivilisation.
Sie kaufen ein Maiensäss
irgendwo ab vom Schuss.
Andere möchten mehr Natur,
aber trotzdem
möglichst gut angebunden sein -
mit ÖV und möglichst gutem WLAN.
Sie wollen nicht unbedingt weg
von der Technik,
auch nicht weg von der Arbeit,
sondern z.B.
einfach etwas mehr Platz.
Ist es die Natur, die wir
v.a. suchen? Macht die glücklich?
Dass Natur glücklich macht,
kennen wir, glaube ich, alle.
Das würde ich bejahen.
- Die Glücksforschung sagt es.
Es ist wissenschaftlich belegt,
dass sie auf unsere Psyche
und unseren Körper
eine positive Auswirkung hat.
Wir gehen aufs Land,
wenn wir im Ferienmodus sind,
entspannt sind oder Sport treiben.
Das macht sicher glücklich.
Ein anderer Punkt ist, dass die
Auseinandersetzung mit der Natur,
Pflanzen, dem spriessenden Grün
etwas Entlastendes hat.
Das ist mir während der Pandemie
stark aufgefallen.
Der Natur kann das nichts anhaben.
Die macht einfach weiter.
Die hat ihr Programm.
Das entlastet uns vielleicht.
Wir denken immer, man muss
hart arbeiten, damit etwas entsteht.
Abgesehen von der Natur:
Was fehlt uns in der Stadt?
Eine Sehnsucht, die viele Menschen
haben, ist das Handanlegen.
Das Gefühl des Haptischen.
Wenn man aufs Land zieht,
ein Ferienhäuslein kauft
oder einen Schrebergarten hat, was
ein "Landmoment" in der Stadt ist,
dann will man mit den Händen
in der Erde buddeln,
selber Konfitüre machen.
Das gehört zum Cottagecore,
dem Trend im Internet
und auf Instagram,
der das Landleben zelebriert.
Das hat der deutsche Soziologe
Hartmut Rosa
mit der Resonanzerfahrung
immer wieder umschrieben:
in Kontakt kommen mit der Welt.
Wir wollen die Welt nicht als stumm
und kalt und technisiert erleben,
sondern das Gefühl haben:
"Die Welt antwortet mir."
"Da gibt es etwas,
worin ich mich spiegeln kann."
Noch ein Aspekt der Stadt,
den ich wichtig finde:
Man hat oft das Bild,
dass die Stadt anonym und kalt sei
und man keine Zugehörigkeit
mehr habe.
Für gewisse Leute
ist aber genau das ein Vorteil:
Zum einen
verschwindet man in dieser Masse.
Wenn man nicht so
mit dem Mainstream schwimmt,
ist man froh,
wenn man das ausleben kann,
ohne - wie im Dorf -
beobachtet zu sein.
Und zweitens
gibt die Masse die Möglichkeit,
Gleichgesinnte zu treffen -
gerade wenn man nicht
zum Mainstream gehört.
Der Druck, sich anzupassen,
ist in der Stadt kleiner.
Landleben macht also glücklich,
wenn man gut dazu passt.
Das ist eine ganz gute Einsicht.
Wenn nicht, kann es
schnell einmal schwierig werden.
Genau so erging es
meinem Kollegen Livio Chistell.
Für uns ging er zurück in das Dorf,
das er in jungen Jahren so schnell
wie möglich verlassen wollte.
Darf ich vorstellen? Flond, ein Teil
der Gemeinde Obersaxen Mundaun.
Hier gibt es eine Beiz,
eine Post, ein paar schöne Ställe,
eine schöne Landschaft
und sonst eigentlich nicht viel.
Von hier bin ich mit 19 abgehauen.
Ich habe mich hier
recht einsam gefühlt.
Ich war der Einzige
in meinem Jahrgang
und fand nicht wirklich Anschluss.
Mich hat das Landleben hier
überhaupt nicht glücklich gemacht.
Ich frage mich,
wie es den Jugendlichen geht,
die heute in Flond leben.
Mit einer habe ich mich verabredet.
Gehen wir sie besuchen!
Das ist Elena Stucki. Sie ist 16,
elf Jahre jünger als ich.
Gehen wir in diese Richtung!
Dort ist es noch schön.
Sie ist hier geboren
und aufgewachsen.
Als ich sie zuletzt sah, war sie
wohl noch ein kleines Mädchen.
Sie fühlt sich wohl auf dem Land.
Der einzige Nachteil ist,
wenn gegüllt wird.
Das kommt häufig vor.
Man steht am Morgen auf,
öffnet das Fenster
und dann riecht man
zuerst mal die Gülle.
Sie ist nicht mehr oft hier.
Unter der Woche
ist sie im Sportgymnasium in Davos.
Sie will nämlich
Profi-Skifahrerin werden.
Das bedeutet viele Trainings
und Rennen in der ganzen Schweiz.
Das Problem mit Flond war für mich,
dass man fast eingesperrt ist.
Ein bisschen ...
* Er schnappt nach Luft. *
Geht dir das nie so?
- Nein.
Ich weiss nicht genau,
wie du das meinst.
Ich musste gehen, um jemanden
zu finden, der wie ich ist,
auf eine gewisse Art.
- Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass sich
viele Leute in Dörfern so fühlen.
Ja, das verstehe ich schon,
auf eine gewisse Art.
Aber ich hatte auch andere Kollegen,
die mir ähnlicher waren,
die ich vom Skifahren kannte.
Eben, ausserhalb des Dorfes.
Ja, ja.
- Siehst du!
Auch früher war ich nicht nur
in der Flond-Bubble.
Ja, in der Flond-Bubble.
* Elena spricht rätoromanisch. *
Du fragst, ob ich es schön finde,
nach Hause zu kommen.
Total. Ich bin total gerne hier.
Es ist so schön. Ich meine, schau
dir dieses Dorf an! Es ist so süss.
Und ich freue mich auch, zurück-
zukommen, meine Eltern zu besuchen,
Leute zu sehen, die schon
während meiner Kindheit hier waren.
Flond
ist wie eine wunderschöne Postkarte,
die deshalb
aber auch etwas stillsteht -
typisch für diese Region.
Und wie vielen anderen Jugendlichen
wurde mir das
irgendwann zu langweilig.
Heute hat das Dorf
224 Einwohner:innen.
Eine Handvoll davon
sind Jugendliche.
Es kann gut sein, dass man
ganz alleine im Jahrgang aufwächst,
wie ich damals.
Die Nächste, die ich treffe,
ist Antonella Messmer.
Sie ist 18,
Fachmittelschülerin in Ilanz.
Vor drei Jahren
ist sie hierhergezogen.
Ihr Vater ist in Flond aufgewachsen.
Antonella kennt das Dorf von den
vielen Besuchen bei den Grosseltern.
Im Dorf kenne ich nicht viele Leute,
auch niemanden in meinem Alter.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt
mit Leuten in meinem Alter im Dorf.
Wenn ich Kollegen treffen will,
muss ich nach Ilanz gehen.
Die Ruhe und die Natur gefallen ihr.
Aber eben: Ihr Umfeld ist anderswo.
Und ein Umfeld in der Nähe zu haben,
vermisse sie schon.
Zum Glück gibt es noch das Handy,
ihren Draht zur Aussenwelt.
Soll ich dir
die Bildschirmzeit zeigen?
Gerne.
Sie ist ziemlich hoch.
Ich bin nicht stolz darauf.
Ich versuche,
sie auch zu reduzieren.
Es sind 6 Std.
- Und das jeden Tag.
34 % reduziert.
Früher waren es 9-10 Std.
Kein Witz?
Ich wünschte, es wäre nicht so,
aber es ist so.
Wenn ich hier so isoliert bin ...
Das klingt, als wäre ich in einem
Gefängnis, aber so ist es ja nicht.
Aber ich bin oft alleine.
Meine Leute sind kurzfristig
nur so erreichbar.
Das mit der Einsamkeit
kommt mir bekannt vor.
Und wir hatten damals
nicht einmal Smartphones.
Aber man kann das Ganze
auch positiv sehen.
Z.B., wenn man gerne Ruhe hat,
wie der 16-jährige Enea Meyer.
Er ist glücklich hier.
Im Sommer fing er in der Dorf-
schreinerei eine Schreinerlehre an.
Sein Umfeld
ist im Nachbardorf Obersaxen,
wo die Flonder:innen
auch zur Schule gehen.
Dort ist auch der Ausgang
an den Wochenenden.
Das Velo nimmt er mit, um später
damit nach Hause zu fahren,
denn am Abend
fahren keine Postautos mehr.
Du nimmst einen krassen Weg
auf dich, um Freunde zu treffen.
Ja.
Der Rufalipark,
wo er seine Freunde trifft,
ist eine Freizeitanlage in Obersaxen.
Trefft ihr euch immer
zur gleichen Zeit am gleichen Ort?
Wir verabreden eine Zeit
und treffen uns hier.
Miguel bringt meistens
etwas zu trinken mit,
die anderen manchmal auch.
Öfters enthält es Alkohol.
Weil ich filme, kommen heute
die meisten seiner Kollegen nicht.
Sonst laufe etwas mehr.
Die Jugend aus der Gegend
chillt hier bis in die Nacht.
Diesen Ort hat es zu meinen Zeiten
noch gar nicht gegeben.
Und ob ich effektiv jedes Wochenende
unter die Leute gegangen wäre,
weiss ich auch nicht.
Fazit nach den Gesprächen
mit diesen Jugendlichen:
Das Leben im Dorf
ist für die ein Glück,
die hier Gleichgesinnte finden.
Bei so wenigen Gleichaltrigen
ist das nicht selbstverständlich.
Das war damals schon so
und daran hat sich nichts geändert.
(Mona) Auf dem Land aufzuwachsen,
ist das eine.
Von den Eltern
aufs Land verpflanzt zu werden,
ist nochmals
eine ganz andere Geschichte.
Ich bin in Ormalingen, Kanton
Baselland, rund 2'000 Einwohner.
Hier treffe ich Familie Schärer,
die vor 15 Jahren entschied,
hierherzuziehen,
und seither immer mal wieder
mit dem Landleben hadert.
Nun sitze ich im wunderschönen
Vorgarten der Familie Schärer.
Das sind Natalie, Raymond,
Tochter Nina, Sohn Julian,
und Fabian Müller,
ein Freund der Familie.
Ihr habt mir vorhin erzählt,
dass es dieses wunderbare Haus war,
in das ihr euch verliebt habt,
und weswegen ihr euch
entschlossen habt, hierherzuziehen.
Natalie,
was hast du vom Landleben erwartet?
Ich habe mir
keine Überlegungen gemacht.
Ich habe mich nicht
darauf vorbereitet,
was auf mich zukommt,
was mich vielleicht erwartet.
Ich bin hier aufgewachsen.
Ich wusste, was mich erwartet.
Aber ich fühlte mich alt genug,
um zurückzukommen.
Ja.
Zu Beginn merkte ich,
dass alle übereinander reden,
weil alle einander irgendwie kennen.
Das hat mich verunsichert,
z.T. wirklich auch gestresst.
Das konnte ich komplett ablegen.
Aber wir haben zu Beginn
viel darüber gesprochen.
Er sagte: "Das ist einfach so.
Das kann dir doch egal sein."
Aber das war es nicht.
Das Bedürfnis,
mich integriert zu fühlen
und nicht zu wissen wie,
damit es wirklich mein Weg ist,
war in den ersten Jahren präsent.
* Verkehrslärm *
Jetzt fällt mir gerade auf:
Ihr seid ja aufs Land gezogen,
um etwas Ruhe zu haben.
Wenn ein Auto vorbeifährt,
verstehe ich euch kaum.
Wusstet ihr, dass ihr
direkt an der Hauptstrasse wohnt?
Unsere Adresse heisst Hauptstrasse.
Eigentlich schon.
Aber es stimmt: Den Verkehr
muss man wirklich ausblenden.
Ich habe es gelernt.
Heute fällt es mir
auch wieder mehr auf.
Am Wochenende ist es katastrophal
mit all den Motorrädern.
Wenn man an der Autobahn
oder an einer Eisenbahnlinie wohnt,
gewöhnt man sich daran.
Es fällt uns stark auf,
wenn Freunde aus der Stadt sagen:
"Aber hallo,
hier ist es lauter als bei uns."
Bei uns ist es
ganz klar leiser im Quartier.
Du wohnst jetzt wieder in Basel,
in der Stadt.
Ja.
Ihr seid nicht alleine gekommen.
Ihr hattet Kinder.
Wie alt warst du?
- Ich war 14.
Ein anspruchsvolles Alter.
Ja.
- Wie war der Umzug für dich?
Ich fand es nicht so lustig.
Das ist schön gesagt,
wenn man mit 14
etwas "nicht so lustig" findet.
Warst du wütend auf deine Eltern,
dass sie an einen Ort zogen,
an dem dir nicht wohl war?
Nicht unbedingt wütend,
aber schon frustriert.
Ja. Wie war das für euch,
als ihr gemerkt habt,
ihr habt euer Traumhaus gefunden,
aber er fühlt sich nicht wohl?
Er hatte wirklich einige Krisen.
Aber mir war nicht klar,
dass dies der Hauptgrund war.
Er war ja in der Teenagerphase.
Erst viel später, als wir
immer wieder darüber geredet hatten,
wurde mir bewusst: "Oh nein,
wir haben ihn wirklich entwurzelt."
Nina, du warst jünger.
Du gingst gerne reiten
und hast es am Anfang
total super gefunden.
Ich könnte mir vermutlich
keine bessere Kindheit vorstellen.
Ich kam hierher,
trat all diesen Vereinen bei,
TV Ormalingen, Mädchenriege ...
Und ich konnte immer reiten gehen.
Es gab so viele Möglichkeiten.
Dort drüben ist ein Bauernhof,
auf dem ich jeden Tag half.
Dann kommen wir zu Fabian.
Du bist aus der Stadt.
Du bist überzeugter Städter.
Du wohnst in Basel.
Könntest du dir vorstellen ...
Du wirst Vater, nicht wahr?
Ja, ich werde
in einigen Wochen Vater.
Könntest du dir vorstellen,
mit der Familie aufs Land zu ziehen?
Das ist für mich kein Grund,
darüber nachzudenken.
Das ist so ein Bild,
dass eine Familie aufs Land geht.
Ich bin nicht so aufgewachsen.
Ich sehe das nicht als Vorteil.
Ich stelle mir eher vor,
dass man in einem Häuschen landet,
beide Eltern ein Auto haben
und zum Chauffeur der Kinder werden.
Ich mache alles mit dem Velo.
Ich bin in 5 Min. überall.
Ich habe ein Lastenvelo, mit dem
ich alles transportieren kann.
In der Stadt
gibt es auch alles in Gehdistanz.
Das funktionierende Dorf
ist mittlerweile die Stadt.
Es ist sehr interessant, dass Julian,
der am meisten Probleme hatte,
die tiefsten Wurzeln geschlagen hat.
Du bist jetzt
in der Ausbildung zum Winzer.
Du wohnst zwar in der Stadt,
aber du arbeitest in der Natur.
Ein bisschen
hat dich das schon geprägt.
Ja, es hat mich definitiv geprägt.
Und mit etwas Abstand
und mit dem Älterwerden
habe ich auch durchaus
die tollen Seiten
kennen- und schätzen gelernt.
Ich finde das spannend.
Das Bewusstsein
für biodynamische Prozesse ...
Du arbeitest
in einem biodynamischen Betrieb.
Das ist schon sehr städtisch.
Die Thematik ist dort sehr aktuell.
Mittlerweile
haben wir Monokulturen auf dem Land
und in den Städten
eine höhere Biodiversität.
Gerade auch bei den Behörden
herrscht ein hohes Bewusstsein
für das, was es eigentlich braucht.
Das fehlt auf dem Land.
Das sieht man sehr oft
in politischen Entscheidungen.
Das Bewusstsein für
eine ausgewogene Nutzung der Natur,
aber auch für die Förderung
der Natur, wo es nötig ist,
ist in der Stadt höher. Die Stadt
ist bei solchen Themen weiter.
Wie gross ist dieser
Stadt-Land-Graben mittlerweile?
Ich glaube, der ist riesig,
v.a. politisch.
Spürt ihr den Stadt-Land-Graben auch?
Ich spüre ihn insofern, als dass ich
von meiner politischen Haltung her
eine eher städtische Sicht einnehme.
Ich rede eigentlich sehr selten
mit den Leuten im Dorfumfeld
über Politik.
Das finde ich unangenehm.
Das bringt mich
in eine komische Situation,
da ich dort anders denke,
als die meisten um mich rum.
Das ist ein grosser Punkt,
das stimmt.
Aber man muss schon sehen:
Auch auf dem Land
gibt es ein politisches Spektrum.
Progressive Kräfte
gibt es nicht nur in der Stadt.
Die progressiven Kräfte
gibt es genauso auf dem Land.
Da möchte ich etwas gegen
den Stadt-Land-Konflikt sprechen,
damit man ihn nicht
als stärker darstellt, als er ist.
Es finden
politische Polarisierungen statt,
aber nicht nur
zwischen Stadt und Land.
Die passieren sowohl in der Stadt
als auch auf dem Land.
Wenn man die Perspektive umkehrt,
seid ihr die,
die man nicht so gerne hat.
Ihr zieht aufs Land,
profitiert von der Natur,
aber macht nicht mit in den Vereinen,
unterstützt die Gemeinschaft nicht.
Gut, aber wir kaufen z.B. lokal ein.
Wir gehen nicht nach Rheinfelden
zum Einkaufen.
Wir kaufen vom Bauer nebenan.
So nimmt man auf eine Art
auch teil an der Gemeinschaft.
Wir haben schon auch teilgenommen.
Wir sind an Dorffeste gegangen.
Wir waren auch einmal am Banntag.
Da läuft man die Gemeindegrenze ab.
Wir haben uns schon bemüht.
Und ich denke,
das wurde auch geschätzt.
Ich denke, wir waren zu einem
grossen Teil integriert durch mich,
weil ich im Verein war,
und auch durch die Schule.
Durch den Verein
nahm ich an vielen Wettkämpfen
in verschiedenen Dörfern teil,
oder auch am Rudin-Lauf,
der in Ormalingen stattfindet,
ein Lauf im Wald.
So war ich ein wenig
eine Tür zum Dorfleben.
Ihr hadert immer mal wieder
mit dem Landleben.
Bleibt ihr hier
oder geht ihr irgendwann zurück?
Ich glaube fest, früher oder später
gehen wir wieder in die Stadt.
Stadt und Land nicht einfach
als geografische Begriffe,
sondern als Denkweise,
als Mentalität.
Und dass es fürs Glück
nicht nur wichtig ist,
dass die Natur schön ist,
sondern auch, dass man sie
mit Menschen teilen kann,
die ähnliche Werte vertreten.
* Melancholisches, jiddisches Lied:
"Arum dem fayer" *
Ich bin wieder in der Frauen-WG
in Dittingen, im Baselbiet.
# ... mit blumen krantsen,
# arum dem fayer
mir freylekh tantsn.
# Vayl tants un lid is undzer lebn.
# Dernokh in shlof khaloymes shvebn.
Die Frauen-WG bereitet sich
auf das Fest am Abend vor.
Zum ersten Mal seit sie hier leben,
wollen sie ihre Nachbarn einladen.
Sich zu integrieren
sei ihnen wichtig.
Wegen Corona war ein solches Fest
bisher nicht möglich.
Jetzt ist es
wie bei "Landfrauenküche".
"Landfrauenküche" der anderen Art.
Was gibt es heute?
Zuerst gibt es eine Juni-Bowle.
Ich habe vor einem Monat Waldmeister
gesammelt und einen Sirup gemacht.
Focaccia mit Wildkräutern
von draussen.
Dann haben wir
noch Brennnesselpesto,
weil wir sehr viele Brennnesseln
jäten mussten.
Ja.
Da fand ich, ich mache Pesto.
- Klingt fein.
Es ist etwas bitter.
Darum sagten wir ...
- Ihr gebt es den Gästen.
... wir verfeinern es
und rollen es in Blätterteig ein.
Dann nimmt es
den Geschmack vom Blätterteig an.
Das scheint mir mutig:
Du verwertest so etwas
beim ersten Besuch der Nachbarn.
Du gibst ihnen
bitteres Brennnesselpesto.
Er ist schon fein.
- Sicher?
Der Frauen-WG ist es wichtig,
möglichst viel von dem,
was die Natur aus der Umgebung
hergibt, zu verwerten.
Autark zu leben
sei aber nicht das Ziel.
Das ist nicht alles aus eurem Garten,
oder?
Nein, nein.
Der Rhabarber ist vom Markt.
Wir gehen immer am Freitagmorgen
auf den Markt in Laufen.
Habt ihr eigentlich ein Auto?
Oder wie seid ihr mobil?
Nein, wir nehmen das Velo.
Und Mira hat einen Elektroroller.
- Okay.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem,
wenn man so weit ab vom Schuss wohnt
und man kein Auto hat.
Und der Bus fährt auch ...
* Sie lacht. *
Der letzte fährt um 20.30 Uhr.
Danach muss man
schon fast ein Taxi nehmen.
Oder man geht 45 Min. zu Fuss.
Wäre das ein Argument
gegen das Landleben?
Wie ist das bei dir?
Wie viel pendelst du?
Im Moment
eigentlich nur zum Arbeiten,
weil die Uni online ist.
Aber schon mehrmals pro Woche.
Manchmal nehme ich auch das Motorrad
in die Stadt.
Es ist schon mühsam,
wenn es mehrere Stationen braucht,
bis man endlich in der Stadt ist.
Für mich
ist das schon eine Belastung.
Das Pendeln ist ein negativer Aspekt
des Landlebens.
Aber das ist eine Frage des Typs,
ob man sich darauf einlassen kann.
Wann hast du gemerkt,
dass es anfängt, dich zu stressen?
Fast von Anfang an.
-Okay.
Ich hatte die Hoffnung,
dass sich das legt.
Ich hatte grosse Bedenken,
dass es nicht weggeht,
oder dass es mich stressen würde.
Ich hoffte, es würde weggehen,
aber es ging nicht weg.
Das ist immer noch so.
Das ist ein Punkt, weshalb ich
zurück in die Stadt möchte.
Ist das beschlossene Sache?
- Ja, ja.
Zu einer Freundin ins Gundeli.
Mitten rein.
Okay. Das ist aber
auch wieder ein Kulturschock.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Im Moment habe ich zwar mein Ideal,
im Garten zu arbeiten
und das Gemeinschaftsleben,
aber für mich
ist es nicht die Realität.
Mein Fokus liegt auf der Stadt.
Mein Leben passiert dort.
Okay.
Darum ist es für mich
nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt,
um auf dem Land zu leben.
- Ja.
Was mir Johanna eben erzählt hat,
hat mich doch etwas überrascht.
Aber das Leben auf dem Land
hat auch seinen Preis.
Wechseln wir nochmals
die Perspektive -
zu denen, die nicht nur auf dem Land,
sondern auch vom Land leben.
Die Bauernfamilie Hunkeler
hat sich auch bei mir gemeldet,
um zu erzählen,
was es für sie bedeutet,
wenn Städter aufs Land ziehen.
Neben unserem Betrieb
wird ein grosses Projekt geplant,
mit insgesamt 160 Wohnungen.
Das sind
diese modernen Kaninchenställe.
Hier werden
grosse Wohnblöcke gebaut.
Meine Angst ist,
jemand kommt hierher und baut das,
aber ist sich
vielleicht gar nicht bewusst,
dass dieser Wohnblock
20 m neben der Jauchegrube steht.
Es kommen vielleicht auch Leute,
die noch nie
auf dem Land gelebt haben.
Manchmal stinkt es auch
oder es ist laut.
Am Anfang
sehen sie die Scheune gar nicht.
Sie schauen raus, sehen diese
Aussicht und denken: "Wunderschön!"
Ein Jahr später kommt das Kind.
Sie sehen die Kühe,
finden sie süss und herzig.
Und im dritten, vierten Jahr,
wenn alles langsam normal ist,
fühlen sie sich gestört.
Und wenn sie etwas Zeit haben,
denken sie:
"Schaden wir dem ein bisschen!"
Davor habe ich Angst.
Bald werden sie ein paar Hundert
neue Nachbarn erhalten,
direkt neben dem Kuhstall.
Eine ziemlich neue Ausgangslage
für den Bauernbetrieb,
den es hier seit Generationen gibt.
Unser Betrieb hier in Wauwil
ist der Betrieb Gasshof,
geführt von der Familie
Hunkeler-Meier.
Madlen und ich
sind das Betriebsleiterpaar.
Wir haben einen Angestellten.
Wir haben zwei Kinder.
Meine Eltern helfen im Betrieb mit.
Das Land der Familie Hunkeler-Meier
ist mehrheitlich weit weg vom Hof.
Rund um den Betrieb
ist praktisch alles verbaut.
Selbst Land verkauft
hat die Familie nie.
Die Gemeinde Wauwil im Kanton Luzern
ist eine Wachstumsgemeinde
und hat sich in den
letzten zehn Jahren stark verändert.
"Wauwil mit Weitsicht"
lautet der Slogan der Gemeinde.
Ländlich, und doch gut erschlossen
mit Bahn und Autobahn,
ist die Wohnlage sehr beliebt.
Aus dem einstigen Bauerndorf
wurde ein Wohnort.
Mami, ich habe die Kuh gestreichelt.
Wir arbeiten hier,
wir wohnen hier, wir leben hier.
Ein normaler Bürger von hier
geht in die Stadt arbeiten
und wohnt hier.
D.h., wenn er hier ist ...
Wauwil ist eine Wohngemeinde,
keine Arbeitsgemeinde.
Hierher kommt man,
um sich zu erholen.
Wenn man hier ist, hat man Freizeit.
Die Neuzuzüger,
die uns nicht so kennen
oder mit der Landwirtschaft
nichts am Hut haben ...
Ich merke, dass die Privaten einen
anderen Ablauf haben als wir zwei,
oder wir alle auf den Bauernhöfen.
Es wäre schön,
wenn manchmal Sonntag wäre,
aber dann macht man trotzdem
dieses und jenes.
Mit Direktverkauf ab Hof suche man
den Kontakt zur Nachbarschaft.
Da wolle man noch mehr investieren.
Verständnis schaffen zwischen
Landwirtschaft und Konsument:innen.
Das Verhältnis zu den Nachbarn
sei grundsätzlich gut
und trotzdem nicht ganz konfliktfrei.
Probleme hatten wir schon
wegen einer Milchkühlungsanlage.
Die steht eigentlich
mitten im Betrieb,
nicht in der Nähe der Nachbarn.
Die hat einen Schall abgegeben,
der für uns nicht relevant war.
Wir haben mit den Nachbarn geredet.
Irgendwann haben wir
eine Messung durchgeführt
und durften dann
mit den Messungen zeigen,
dass die Lautstärke
kein Problem war.
Ich verstand sie aber
und intervenierte,
indem ich
einen Schallschutz installierte.
Ich hoffe,
das ist jetzt gut für sie.
Aber das hat mich
einige Tausend Franken gekostet.
Aber das wird uns in Zukunft
wohl noch ab und zu passieren,
dass man mit den Nachbarn
Konflikte hat,
weil wir eben hier sind.
Aber das ist das Leben auf dem Land.
Miteinander, manchmal
auch ein bisschen gegeneinander.
Um den Dichtestress im Dorf
zu umgehen,
will die Bauernfamilie
den Hof ausserhalb erweitern.
Die Gemeinde
hat das Projekt gutgeheissen.
Hier stehen wir genau an dem Ort,
an dem wir diesen Legehennenstall
bauen möchten.
Warum hier? Im Dorf geht es
wegen der Baukräne nicht mehr.
Der Grund ist, dass die Abstände
zu unseren Nachbarn zu klein wären.
Neben einer Scheune,
die ihnen bereits gehört,
hätten sie bauen wollen,
doch der Kanton lehnte ab.
Der Stall wäre für uns sehr wichtig.
Wir hätten wieder ein
sicheres Standbein für die Zukunft.
Wir sind beide gebildet.
Du bist Meisterlandwirt,
ich bin Bäuerin mit Fachausweis.
Uns wurde eingetrichtert,
innovativ zu sein,
gute Ideen zu haben,
motiviert und kreativ zu sein
und auch mal vehement
etwas durchzusetzen.
Da sind wir immer dran.
Und gleichzeitig -
wie bei vielen jungen Bauern -
scheitert es einfach
an den Bewilligungen.
Aber das Projekt
geben wir ganz sicher nicht auf.
Wir machen das für uns
und nicht einfach zum Spass.
Wir haben auch schon
sehr viel Geld investiert.
Wauwil sei auch für sie
ein Wohntraum,
sagen Madlen und Markus Hunkeler.
Ihren Betrieb würden sie gerne an
die nächste Generation weitergeben.
Die Zukunft ist einfach unsicher.
Ja,
im Moment ist die Lage noch ruhig,
aber irgendwann
wird es prekär für uns.
Nicht wahr?
* Melancholische Klänge *
Der Konflikt zwischen denen,
die aufs Land ziehen,
um dort ihre Freizeit
und die Natur zu geniessen,
aber in der Stadt arbeiten,
und denen,
die dort arbeiten, z.B. Bauern,
tritt immer wieder auf.
Hat die Philosophie eine Lösung
für diese zwei Ansprüche ans Land?
Das finde ich schwierig.
Da treffen Präferenzen aufeinander.
Die grundlegendste Frage
ist immer wieder:
Wem gehört eigentlich der Boden?
Wem gehört das Land?
Und wer darf entsprechend
auch darüber bestimmen?
Und was ganz wichtig ist:
Wir leben in einer Demokratie.
Die Schweiz
ist eben geprägt von beidem,
von städtischen Regionen,
in denen viele Leute leben,
aber auch von ländlichen Regionen.
Und wenn es um Vernehmlassungen
für Gesetzesentwürfe geht,
ist es z.B. ganz wichtig,
dass man die Pluralität
in der Schweiz anhört.
Das wird ja auch gemacht.
Die Städteverbände
werden einbezogen,
genauso
wie der Verband der Bergregionen.
Es ist ganz wichtig, dass man
in der Demokratie der Schweiz
wirklich versucht,
das auszuhalten und auszuhandeln.
Ich finde es aber auch wichtig, sich
immer wieder vor Augen zu führen:
Wenn wir den Klimawandel bekämpfen
und eine grünere,
klimaverträgliche Schweiz wollen,
ist natürlich die Zersiedelung
des Landes und die vielen Leute,
die aufs Land ziehen wollen,
ein grosses Problem.
Wenn wir noch mehr verbauen
und alle Leute
immer noch mehr Raum brauchen,
heizen wir auch mehr,
brauchen mehr Strom,
verursachen mehr Emissionen.
Der Klimawandel braucht mehr Stadt.
Der letzte World Happiness Report
hat sich intensiv
mit diesem Thema beschäftigt
und Stadt und Land verglichen.
Was denkst du, global gesehen:
Sind die Leute in den Städten
oder auf dem Land glücklicher?
Da muss ich als Philosophin passen.
- Ja, du musst raten.
Ich muss raten?
- Es gibt eine klare Antwort.
In der Stadt.
- In der Stadt. Warum denkst du das?
Ich glaube, weltweit gesehen gibt es
in der Stadt einfach mehr Arbeit.
Da sind wir
wieder beim Thema Arbeit.
Wir müssen letztlich
unser Überleben sichern.
Das ist eine Existenzfrage - und
Arbeit ist in der Stadt zu finden.
Es ist genau so.
In den allermeisten Ländern der Welt
sind die Leute im Durchschnitt
in der Stadt glücklicher,
aus den Gründen, die du nanntest.
In der Stadt entsteht der Wohlstand.
In ganz vielen Ländern
zieht es die Leute in die Stadt.
Es gibt einige wenige Ausnahmen.
In reichen, westeuropäischen Ländern
sind die Leute
auf dem Land glücklicher. Warum?
Weil man auf dem Land dieselben
Möglichkeiten hat wie in der Stadt.
Man ist sehr gut vernetzt,
muss aber die "Nachteile" der Stadt,
z.B. den Lärm, nicht mittragen.
Den Fünfer und das Weggli haben.
- Fünfer-und-Weggli-Mentalität.
Aber je weiter ab vom Schuss
das "Land" ist,
umso schwieriger wird es häufig auch,
die Jungen dortbehalten zu können.
Dann kommen Dörfer
schnell in eine schwierige Situation,
nämlich, dass das Leben
langsam aber sicher
aus diesen Dörfern verschwindet.
Was man alles unternimmt,
um frisches Blut zu bekommen,
sah man gut am Beispiel Albinen
im Kanton Wallis.
Wir waren vor drei Jahren
zum ersten Mal dort.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Es regnete in Strömen,
als uns der Albiner Gemeindepräsident
damals zum ersten Mal empfing.
Im Prinzip leben wir hier
im Herzen des Wallis,
in einem fantastischen Klima,
sonnig,
kurze Wege in die Kantonshauptstadt,
kurze Wege
in die Industriehauptstadt Visp,
wo sich Lonza befindet.
Trotzdem haben wir einige Nachteile,
die uns schwer zu schaffen machen.
Erstens haben wir keine Schule mehr.
Das ist ein grosses Handicap.
Zweitens stehen wir
in einer grossen Konkurrenz -
nicht zur "Üsserschwiiz", sondern
zu den grösseren Orten im Tal.
Die versuchen, unsere Leute
und auch alles andere abzusaugen.
Die machen uns das Leben
sehr schwer.
Es wäre schade, wenn wir
zu einem Rentnerweiler verkämen
und eines Tages
noch aussterben würden.
Corona war noch weit entfernt,
die Vorstellung,
dass Bergdörfer eine Renaissance
erleben könnten, undenkbar.
Schauen wir mal, was wir hier haben.
Heute ist das Berggebiet
kein Faktor mehr in der Schweiz.
Selbst im Bundesrat weiss
seit Adolf Ogis Abgang niemand mehr,
wo sich das Berggebiet befindet.
Das ist ein Drama.
Im Kanton denkt man
auch den ganzen Tag darüber nach,
wie man die kleinen Gemeinden
beseitigen könnte.
Albinen half sich selbst.
Junge im Dorf
legten der Gemeindeversammlung
eine sog. Wohnbau-
und Familienförderinitiative vor.
Anders ausgedrückt:
Wer nach Albinen zieht, bekommt Geld.
Das Volk stimmte zu und
Tausende von Leuten aus aller Welt
wollten in dieses Walliser Bergdorf
ziehen.
Das sind Bewerbungen.
Man könnte meinen,
es ginge um einen Job.
Referenzen, Zeugnisse, Fotos, CDs.
Sehen Sie, das ist das Bild
einer Familie, die schreibt:
"This is our family."
Eine riesige Familie.
Das war 2004.
Ein Baby fehle darauf noch.
Ja, es ist interessant.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Elma Anthamatten
und Roger Haudenschild
gehörten zu den Auserwählten.
Dank der Wohnbauförderung konnten
sie sich in Albinen ein Haus kaufen.
Das ist unser neues Daheim.
Es herrscht noch Unordnung, weil wir
noch nicht so eingerichtet sind.
Aber das eine oder andere
sieht man sicher.
Hier ist das Schlafzimmer.
- Schlafzimmer, aber das ist nur ...
Wir haben mal etwas aufgestellt.
Unsere Matratze
kommt in einer oder zwei Wochen.
Dann sieht es nicht mehr aus,
als hätte eine Bombe eingeschlagen.
Je 25'000 Fr. haben sie von
der Gemeinde als Zustupf erhalten,
weil sie in Albinen in ein Haus
investierten und dort leben wollen.
Ich finde das nicht komisch.
Das ist eher Liebe zum Detail,
weil man halt wirklich
an diesem Dorf hängt
und alles versucht,
damit das Dorf nicht ausstirbt.
Wir haben hier unsere Ruhe.
Was will man noch mehr?
- Nichts.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Drei Jahre später treffen wir
Roger Haudenschild wieder.
Elma Anthamatten und er
haben sich getrennt.
Sie lebt nicht mehr in Albinen.
Wie habt ihr es
mit der Wohnbauförderung gemacht?
Ich habe den Betrag zurückbezahlt,
den sie der Gemeinde schuldete.
War das kein Problem?
- Das war kein Problem.
Bezahlt man den vollen Betrag
oder einen Teil zurück?
Den vollen Betrag.
- Okay.
Was machst du?
Bleibst du in Albinen?
Im Moment schon.
Man weiss nie, was das Leben bringt.
* Er pfeift. *
Gehen wir?
Was er brauche, habe er hier:
Ruhe und Natur.
Der Gemeindepräsident Beat Jost.
Nach drei Jahren Wohnbauförderung
zieht er Bilanz.
Wir sind
Erfolg versprechend unterwegs.
Wir gehen
in eine gute, richtige Richtung.
Das ist die neuste Übersicht.
Einfach zur Dokumentation.
Wohnbau- und Familienförderung
von Albinen.
Hier haben wir alle Gesuche.
Wir haben z.B. bis jetzt
16 Gesuche bewilligt.
Das betrifft 35 Personen.
Wir haben rund 760'000 Fr.
an Beiträgen bewilligt.
Es gibt diverse Förderprogramme
in verschiedensten Regionen,
im Alpenraum, im Berggebiet.
Von allen Modellen,
die ich bis jetzt angeschaut habe,
ist das Modell Albinen jedoch
nach wie vor das interessanteste.
Im Dorf gab es aber
auch immer schon Kritik dagegen.
Ich finde es schlecht.
Sehr schlecht.
Warum?
Die haben hier
noch nie Steuern bezahlt.
Wir haben unser Leben lang
Steuern bezahlt.
Dann sollen sie uns Alten
auch einmal Steuern erlassen.
Du kannst doch zufrieden sein,
wenn du Steuern bezahlen kannst,
dann hast du etwas verdient.
Die Mutter
ist nicht gleicher Meinung.
Nein.
Nein. Nein, da werden wir nie
gleicher Meinung sein.
Ist es Quatsch?
Es ist nicht Quatsch.
Ich sagte, ich sei nicht dafür.
Fertig. Ich habe meine Meinung,
er hat seine Meinung.
Wunderbar. Siehst du,
so gehen die Meinungen auseinander.
Soll ich ehrlich sein?
Ich nicht unbedingt.
Jeder muss mit Herz und Gefühl
hierher wohnen kommen.
Er muss mit Freude hierherkommen.
Was sagt der Gemeindepräsident dazu?
- Er ist nicht gleicher Meinung.
Aber ich finde einfach,
man muss an der Natur Freude haben
und hier mit Freude wohnen.
Das ist gut.
- Das ist meine Meinung.
Ich komme dann nochmals vorbei.
- Ich hoffe es.
Das fanden nie alle im Dorf gut.
Das wäre ja ein Wunder.
100 Leute haben damals
an der Urversammlung abgestimmt.
70 waren dafür, 30 dagegen.
Mindestens dieses Resultat
würden wir heute wieder erreichen.
Vielleicht sogar ein noch besseres.
- Ach ja?
Dass wir unsere Einwohnerzahl
halten können, ist schon sehr gut.
Corona hat uns
einige Möglichkeiten aufgetan,
indem Leute plötzlich merkten:
Ich kann ja auch hier arbeiten.
Das ist gar kein Problem.
In ihrem Tiny House
inmitten der Bergwelt
funktioniere Homeoffice perfekt,
sagen Lea und Pierre Biege.
Machst du Pommes frites?
Und bums.
Im Sommer 2020
sind sie hier eingezogen.
Es ist halt rundum
noch nicht ganz fertig.
Es ist immer noch eine Baustelle,
weil wir noch auf einen Teil
der Bewilligungen warten.
Aber kommt doch mal rein.
Albinen habe sie offen empfangen,
nicht wie andere.
Es ist ein spezielles Projekt,
und wir haben
mehrere Gemeinden angefragt.
Es ist ein gutes Projekt
für Wohnverdichtung
oder Flächenzwischennutzung.
Aber es wurde uns schwer gemacht.
Entweder kam gar kein Feedback,
oder dann:
"Was ist das
für ein komisches Projekt?"
"Erklärt das mal genauer!"
Da haben wir uns
gar nicht wohlgefühlt.
Wir stiessen immer auf Skepsis.
Hier gab es von Anfang an
keine Skepsis.
Sondern: Ja, wenn ihr die Standards
für ein Haus erfüllt.
Und das tun wir.
Wohnen und arbeiten auf dem Land -
und ab und zu
für einen Job in die Stadt gehen.
Pierre und Lea Biege sagen,
dies hier entspräche
ziemlich exakt ihrem Lebensideal.
Auch Severin Hermann
hat in Albinen gefunden,
was er zum Leben braucht.
Er ist hier aufgewachsen
und will bleiben.
Er hat ein kleines Geschäft
mit Kräutern aufgebaut
und bepflanzt die alten Terrassen
des Dorfes wieder.
Man muss nicht immer alles
in Geld rechnen.
Das ist meine Überlegung.
Das Niveau ist ein bisschen tiefer
und ich habe mehr Zeit.
Und mir gefällt, was ich mache.
Aber das
muss nicht bei jedem so sein.
Ich würde niemandem sagen,
das sei das einzig Richtige.
Es ist für mich richtig, fertig.
Die Stärke des Dorfes ist ja,
dass es übersichtlich ist,
dass jeder gebraucht wird,
dass man mitgestalten kann.
Das bringt man
mit einem Dorf in Verbindung.
Die, die herkommen,
wollen nicht mehr anonym leben
wie in der Agglomeration
von Schlieren oder Wallisellen.
Hier ist man jemand.
Ich kann mich engagieren
und das Dorf mitprägen.
Ob das Landleben glücklich macht,
weiss ich nicht,
aber Albinen macht glücklich,
denn in Albinen
leben wir im Paradies.
Im Sommer 2022
soll gar die Schule wieder aufgehen.
Von den Walliser Bergen
ins Laufental -
nach Dittingen zur Frauen-WG.
Die Zugezogenen wollen sich heute mit
einem Fest ins Dorfleben integrieren.
* Mira spielt Klavier und singt. *
# We're eye to eye and soul to soul.
# There is no time anymore
to run away.
Wir haben eine Bowle,
Wasser, Sirup ...
Fast vegan, aber nicht ganz.
Wir haben
auch nicht-vegane Mitbewohner.
Nur die Schokoladenwürfel
enthalten ein wenig Vollmilchpulver.
Elisabeth.
- Johanna. Hallo, freut mich.
Hallo zusammen.
- Mira. Ich wohne auch hier.
Dort hinten
sind die ersten Gäste eingetroffen.
Aber etwas
wollen wir jetzt noch rasch klären:
Zu Beginn der Sendung
lernten wir Xenia und Tinu kennen,
die aufs Land zogen
und ein Haus bauten.
Ist das Haus inzwischen fertig?
Das stimmt gar nicht.
- Aber das ist ja schon lange so.
Ja, aber die hier
sind natürlich auf Mass.
Gut, das ist nicht so schlimm.
Das ist am Boden.
Die kann man
mit der Flex ausschneiden.
Aber das machen nicht wir.
- Da kann ich auch nichts dafür.
Wir haben es deinem Monteur
wirklich noch gesagt.
Wir sagten, diese Masse
stimmen wahrscheinlich nicht.
Bring mal den Flex!
Sie hören es:
Es wäre ja nicht normal,
wenn der Bau eines Eigenheims auf
dem Land reibungslos klappen würde.
Wir sind eigentlich auf gutem Weg,
aber es hapert momentan
noch mit zwei, drei kleinen Sachen.
Ja, der Ofen ist noch ein Thema.
Innentüren werden wir beim Umzug
noch keine haben.
Aber dadurch passen
die Möbel besser hindurch.
Das ist ein Vorteil.
- Das ist ganz praktisch.
Alle sagen immer, es sei stressig.
Aber bis du selber baust,
hast du keine Ahnung,
wie stressig es wirklich ist.
Es ist
eine sehr, sehr grosse Belastung.
Logisch gibt es dir am Schluss
auch ganz viel,
aber wenn man mittendrin steckt
und einem alles bis hier steht,
ist es nicht lustig.
Aber wir wollen uns nicht beklagen.
Schlussendlich
ist es eine tolle Chance.
Am Ende haben wir dann ein Haus.
Das ist es wert.
Prost.
- Cheers.
* Mira spielt Klavier und singt. *
# From all the countries
we rise up.
# The youth, the old, all say stop.
# We know what has to be done.
Schön, seid ihr alle hier
bei uns im Garten
und feiert mit uns
die Nachbarschaft.
Das Buffet ist eröffnet.
(Alle) Zum Wohl!
Alle Nachbarn werden
zum Essen von Brennnesseln bekehrt -
ich auch.
Ich beleidige Brennnesselpesto
nie mehr.
Es ist sehr fein.
Das freut dich jetzt, nicht?
- Ja.
Ich habe es vorhin
auch nicht so gut verkauft.
Was hast du gedacht,
als die jungen Frauen gekommen sind?
Ganz ehrlich?
"Wie lange bleiben sie wohl?"
Weshalb?
Weil es sehr viele Wechsel gab.
Jeder verdient eine Chance.
Sie sollen es versuchen.
Einigen gefällt es nicht
und dann gehen sie wieder,
anderen gefällt es.
Man schaut einfach mal.
Wie ist es für dich?
Du gehst ja bald weg.
Ich gehe ja nicht im Streit.
Ich werde mich selber einladen
und zurückkommen.
Es ist nicht fertig,
es wird einfach weniger intensiv.
Aber ich darf nach wie vor
im Garten helfen.
Macht Landleben glücklich?
Je nach Lebensmoment
und wie es in die Realität passt.
Und dich?
Im Moment nicht, sonst
ginge ich nicht in die Stadt zurück.
Aber als Ideal schon.
Mira? Macht Landleben glücklich?
- Mich macht es sehr glücklich.
(Mira) # Uh.
# From all the countries
we rise up.
# The youth, the old, all say stop.
# We know what has to be done.
# We are earthlings,
we are one, we are one.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretypegmbh - 2021